this is the show where we talk about
money in a way everyone can understand
it in a way that applies to everyone the
danger of these simple concepts is those
of you that view yourself as
intellectuals those of you that view
yourself as sophisticated sometimes you
look at something that's simple and you
don't understand how profound it is like
the borrower is slave to the lender oh
but I use credit cards to get my miles
you actually think you're going to take
on a multi-billion dollar company who
studies your behavior more than you
study your behavior and come out on the
right end of this stick that doesn't
make you sophisticated that makes you
blatantly stupid think about it did you
know the credit card is the most
aggressively marketed product in the
history of humankind
nothing has been sold to anyone in any
culture in any kind of a volume close to
the credit card no product line or
service has had anywhere near as much
money spent on marketing and
sophistication to sell it to you
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
is spent to sell you this product and
then you're so stupid that you think
you're going to get away with using it
for free if you do it's gonna be a
short-term thing or if you think you do
you left out some of the variables
example when you spend using cash it
activates the pain centers of your brain
you have an ouchy moment when you hand
over uncle Benjamin Franklin dad gum I
just bought dinner
when you Laye uncle Benjamin Franklin in
that black plastic tray known as his
coffin because he's going away and he's
not coming back you put him inside that
little visa or American Express
fold-over vinyl thing that the server
brings you and you lay uncle Benjamin
Franklin in there you have a moment with
Uncle Ben Uncle Bill I'll never see you
again you know this is happening when
you pay with plastic and I interview you
24 hours later you don't know what the
total was on the bill you can't tell me
what you spent you don't know what you
spent at the gas pump cuz you stuck a
card in it you pump the gas and you
walked away you can't tell me what your
gas bill was in the days that we used to
walk into the market and lay money down
on the counter and then they would give
you change because you didn't round it
off when you were putting your gas in we
knew exactly what we spent on gas in
those days today you don't even know
what your gas is you don't know I use a
debit card I can't tell you what mine
was can I tell you what it costs to fill
up my truck the other day I don't know I
didn't notice it stuck the card in put
the gas in drove away I'm just like you
cash activates the pain centers of the
brain there's two or three things that
activate memory memory is activated
primarily by pain fear heavy emotion of
some kind positive pleasurable emotion
will activate memory that's why you
smell something and you remember a girl
you dated in high school
smell activates that memory that's what
happens and so it's that that's the
process so so here's the thing if you
can't remember it it means the pain
centers of your vain brain we're not
activated and when we do surveys with
what you spend on that meal as you walk
out of the door the restaurant you can't
tell me what the total was twenty-five
dollars around fifty-two dollars I don't
know fifty six fifty silver four
I don't know I don't even remember I
think I left the tip left the big tip
because I've been drinking you know now
you really can't remember anything right
so this is how people handle their money
and yet you tell me you're gonna beat
the credit card company you spend twelve
to eighteen percent more on average when
you use plastic then when you use cash
that's what all the studies show us
because you don't feel the pain in the
world's worst place is the grocery store
they are the best marketers on the
planet the best merchandisers on the
planet is a grocery store man they know
how to put the food at the right place
old-fashioned example the easiest
example is the bread and the milks at
the back right because everybody that
walks in the grocery store is buying
bread or milk and they have to go
through the full length of the store and
have every opportunity to impulse on
some kind of jar of peanut butter and
jelly mix together pre-mixed for you I
don't know what you're imposing on but
there's something getting your attention
it must be those new peach cheerios I
heard about today and guess what all the
stuff is at the I level they get your
attention and they pay for the shelf
position as you walk to the back to get
your bread and milk and you can't walk
out without spending money it's the the
the the aisles are designed for you to
buy stuff and when you use plastic at
the grocery store you have no idea what
your grocery bill is and you spend more
he's been more on clothing
oh yeah throwing that accessory oh yeah
you'll pick up other people's tab at the
restaurant I'll buy you dinner tonight
nothing anything about just drop 50
bucks never think a thing about it now
I'm not saying you shouldn't be generous
I'm not sure saying you shouldn't
accessorize and I'm not saying you
shouldn't enjoy some purchases at the
grocery store I'm just saying you know
do it on purpose and if you think at
credit card use even if you're paying it
off every month cost you zero then you
are a very naive individual that has
been influenced by an industry that has
spent more to influence you than any
other industry in the history of the
world that should give you pause that
should give you pause if anybody else
was selling
that hard on anything you would your
shields would go up but for some reason
when its credit cards were like oh no
damn I have this figured out I'm 26 and
I've got this figured out I'm 26 years
old I make $42,000 a year but I'm gonna
beat up on old Discover Card they don't
know anything I've got them beat I'm
getting those Discover points not
costing me a thing you know how stupid
that makes you saying when you say stuff
like that I'm making all my money on my
airline miles you know I've met with
thousands of millionaires I have never
met a millionaire said Dave you know I
made all my money on my airline miles
they my breakthrough was my discovery
points
I'll pay mine off every month Dave I'm
beating up on the credit card company
I'm getting the use of their money wink
wink millionaires just don't say stuff
like that
now some of them use a credit card they
do pay it off every month but I got to
tell you their lifestyles are so
conservative
besides you know when I set them up next
to you middle-class people or spending
everything you make and trying to
convince me that I'm a troglodyte
because I don't use credit cards well
I'm not broke anymore this is a
multi-millionaire troglodyte you're
listening to why because I start
understanding that behavior affects your
ability to build wealth more than all
your little math tricks you think you
see all the variables on the borrower is
slave to the lender it doesn't say
except airline miles the borrower is
slave to the lender it doesn't say
except Discover points the borrower is
slave to the lender
it doesn't say except I got 0% interest
on my new car which lost $7,000 when I
drove it off the lot so it's not really
0% is it how stupid are we I mean you're
gonna you're gonna hand me a nickel in
front of me while you're picking a
hundred-dollar bill out of my back
pocket and call me smart think people
think think
if someone shoveling stuff down your
throat at this rate to the rate of
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
and their ability to sell and to market
to you is beyond any other
sophistication of any other marketing
program there must be money in it
follow the money follow the money so I
don't have any credit cards I have to
debit cards didn't do what you want but
it's working for me this is the Dave
Ramsey show